when you're doing your uh tour bus legs
yeah is your tour bus these days wrapped
with obnoxious burnt stuff no
it is completely discreet yeah yeah I uh
I I I I knew from day one I would not be
that guy because I am I don't want
right who's in there I'm the opposite
you know and the [ __ ] first time I
saw Birds bus I was like
I was like you're gonna have everybody
knocking out he goes no and then he
called me he's like dude people are
knocking on the door I go yeah it's got
your face on it bro I the last time I
spoke to burden here yeah I cursed him
it was the bastard I saw you doing it
[ __ ] wrapped my bus of course if you
[ __ ]
of course yeah we have Steve has a sign
that says like it's not okay to knock
yeah it's not okay to knock please do
not disturb and it's on a motion sensor
so when they're walking up to like yeah
that's you have that that that that
diminishes it but it's not eliminated
but like I know that you at least have
that like hey respect me
um um Bert doesn't have that he his sign
might be like go ahead and knock
yeah crazy yeah yeah let me tell you the
machine story oh my God he sits him down
he's like when I was 22 years old
uh how much time does Bert spend in
Austin like
um he I mean you know it's not easy
obviously like he's he's made a huge
sacrifices for it but
yeah he comes in and we try to do
we try to bank you know I mean the show
we always try to make the show is the
two of us we do we call it guest Bears
because we just have to now but like
he'll come in
guest Bears meaning meaning someone sits
in for for one of the two of us so like
I was I was a guest with him yeah and
like this week you know him he and Neil
Brennan are on
um and then like I just had Jana like
you know so people come in so that we
don't we never want to go dark for a
week right right right right
um but like he'll come in he just he was
in town we recorded four together he's
coming in town next month and we'll do
four to we'll do four over two days so
basically we'll do a month of shows in
two days
um I'll try to do something together so
we have like an activity or something
something fun to do but yeah I mean you
know it's just the way to keep the show
going is two bears does it do bigger
numbers than your mom's house uh about
the same they vary I mean like some
weeks
um your mom's house will do better some
weeks two bears I think the um
consistently is huge the most they're
both pretty big they're both pretty big
I mean the yeah it just depends I mean
but they're both pretty solid like big
big shows yeah yeah I mean Bert's gotta
feel a little bit sad about how bertcast
does compared no it's not even close
yeah it's this fly private yes a lot yes
but I fly in much better aircraft
yeah we we uh just a Canada tour and um
for my Newton Newfoundland shows yeah I
always liked it and I'm going private
yes
I'm on your guy's heels man I've been uh
dude when you um I've been I've been um
doing theaters where even like birds
coming up you know like yeah yeah like
uh the electric science like Stevo's
tonight like Bert's you know yeah next
month yeah yeah I'm even in the mix on
the same theater that's rad dude
congratulations thank you super stoked
it's called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude